foreign
I've been working as a personal trainer
for five to six years and how long you
long you've been working with Magnus
Carlson you started working out here is
it about a year ago or something and
when he's home and here we usually do
two times a week
also it's a concentration exercise
because you need to if you tense up it's
going to be really tough because then
you're just reaction to reacting to
every
like that and then we jump around
but really get the
hard way down and really concentrate and
relax to get it done so it's a
combination of both balance
stabilization and a bit of focus in
particular we also do some more balance
training and some training that is a bit
more coordination just to get the
brain to work so here's just a normal
core exercise ab exercise that we do we
do some pull-ups and it's always fun to
use the battle ropes every other
or both
and we have these variations where you
go out and in
the heart rate goes up like like this
what would you say is the most important
in your workouts with magnets for him to
be at his very best when playing chess
the most important for him in particular
is to have the routines getting up
eating well because it's easier to eat
well and perform when you have a daily
routine that works out and there are
studies that show that cardiovascular
training does impact the brain in good
ways it's an endurance part of course
you need to have a lot of endurance to
get your mind to keep on working for
that long I like to challenge Magnus a
lot so we usually do some kind of
competitive rounds at least at the end
of the workouts
go go go go go go go go go
and
stretch out come on come on
and what would you say if uh his uh
biggest strength when it comes to
working out oh it's competitiveness yeah
definitely yeah it takes everything and
makes a competition so his ability to
just
keep on going if I say if it's good he's
not happy until he's happy uh last time
I did this I laid we did eight rounds
huh yeah eight rounds eight rounds and I
just laid on the floor for 10 minutes
after I had to go down and buy a protein
shake and come back up and give it to
him I think after he started here he had
a good winning streak after he turned 30
he didn't have any wins for a while and
then he started working out here so
apparently he got a few wins straight
after so I was like okay I have to write
down the check and take my 10 no but I
mean I I think it was like some kind of
record after that and of course it is
not just that but I mean maybe it has
some impact
oh